un autre lancement réussi pour la Chine
le 22e cette année trois astronautes
dont un civil qui rejoignent le groupe
déjà installé à bord de la station tyang
ces chinois dans l'espace en même temps
un record un autre qui s'ajoute au
blason du géantiatique oui c'est un
exploit le problème chinois accélère
depuis des années on voit que il est
actuellement en deuxième position
derrière les États-Unis mais plus très
loin des États-Unis la Chine parle
pourtant de loin c'est seulement 2003 40
ans après les Russes et les Américains
qu'elle réussit son premier vol habité
un seul astronaute 21 heures de vol
mais depuis 15 ans c'est le grand bon en
avant la Chine a maintenant sa propre
station spatiale qui devrait doubler de
taille au cours des prochaines années un
Rover sur Mars un autre sur la lune qui
a réussi l'exploit de ramener sur terre
des échantillons et d'ici 2030 Pékin
affirme que chinois va foulé le sol
lunaire tout ça avec une technologie
développée un temps record maintenant
donc elle va passer à l'étape suivante
qui est une fois qu'elle a sa station
elle va commencer à s'intéresser elle
aussi à envoyer des humains au-delà de
l'orbite basse donc vers l'avenir on
fait la Chine est tellement ambitieuse
qu'on parle maintenant de nouvelles
courses à l'espace mais pour l'instant
les deux coureurs ne sont pas du même
calibre c'est vrai qu'en 2022 la Chine a
lancé presque autant de fusée que les
États-Unis mais le budget de la Nasa est
deux fois plus élevé et les Américains
contrairement chinois ont de nombreux
partenaires dans l’aventure de la
station spatiale qui a encore beaucoup
d'étapes à franchir dans un programme
spatial c'est complexe mais l'argent la
connaissance le degré technique qu'ils
ont atteint leur permet de vraiment
espérer être parmi les premiers et
largement devancer des Américains dans
le futur est-ce que les chinois
parviendront à mettre le pied sur la
Lune avant les Américains les paris sont
ouverts les chinois ne sont pas inquiets
de savoir s'ils vont arriver sur la Lune
avant ou après le retour des Américains
pour eux la chose importante c'est
qu'ils vont arriver sur la lune à court
terme la Chine prévoit lancer deux
missions habitées par année tout en se
préparant pour la conquête de la lune
mais à long terme l'objectif avouer du
géant asiatique cette conquérir la
première place sur le podium de la
course à l'espace ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal